[Music]
in the east lies the most sinister of
Valerius daughters on the edge of the
Crone River within the vast primordial
forests of esos wakes qohor the city of
sorcerers it is known that the dark arts
are practiced heavily here even to this
day such things as a blood magic and
necromancy even divination are whispered
of even in modern times the vast ancient
forests of qohor have never fully been
explored it is thought that they may
conceal many mysteries and wonders at
its core qohor is the only place in the
known world where the reworking of
Valyrian steel has been preserved and
the secret is guarded heavily still made
in qohor itself is said to be superior
in every way to the best castleforge
still of Westeros maester pol wrote that
during his time in cahorn he was whipped
three times publicly for making too many
inquiries about the process in which
Valyrian steel is reworked in the final
instance his hand was also removed Paul
wrote that the true reason for him being
exiled was his discovery of the blood
sacrifices including the killing of
slaves as young infants in an effort to
reproduce steel equal to that of the
Valyrian freehold qohor is one of the
richest and most exotic of the Free
Cities the wealth of qohor is hidden
within the vast forests the sprawling
towns and the spring cities of the Lower
Roaring River hunger for wood as their
forests have long since been destroyed
beyond qohor lie the fabled lands beyond
the bones and the desolation that was
the kingdom of cenar and the sheer
vastness that is the Dothraki sea for
this reason the [ __ ] is known as the
gateway to the east of the Free Cities
qohor is the most like old Valyria
though the people of qohor do not
possess dragons they have the best
approximation of Valyrian steel and they
are the best at reworking Valyrian steel
they have preserved at least some of the
spells and sorcery left over from the
Valyrian Empire
and lastly they worship at least one
strange and terrible deity the god of
qohor is known as the black goat and he
demands daily blood sacrifices mostly
animals such as horses or cows are used
but it is reported that unholy days
criminals that are condemned go beneath
the knives of cowled priests and it is
even said that the high Nobles in times
of crisis and danger will even offer up
their own children to appease their God
in modern times
relations between qohor and its sister
city norvos have been decent though the
black goat is regarded by the people of
norvos as a demon with an especially
vile and treacherous nature if you are
familiar with Maya Song of Ice and Fire
videos then you know that george RR
martin has often referenced Lovecraft
in relation to gods particularly gods
with malevolent nature this is indeed
another reference and Lovecraftian
mythology shub-niggurath is described as
a perverse fertility baby said to appear
as a large mass of cloud which extrudes
black tinta khals and short writhing
goat legs shil McGraw is often
associated with the phrase the Black
Goat of the woods with a thousand young
according to Lovecraftian mythology the
black goat is the figurehead through
which children de Graaf is worshiped is
the black goat of qohor also the
representative of some entity without
form the Lovecraftian references found
within a Song of Ice and Fire hint at a
far more peculiar world than initially
expected where inconceivable monstrosity
could potentially lurk within every
corner hidden to the inhabitants of the
planet and perhaps it is better that
such entities stay hidden
Georgia Martin has stated that no gods
will ever appear in his series and to
quote H P Lovecraft's the call of
cthulhu we live on a placid island of
ignorance in the midst of black seas of
infinity and it was not meant that we
should voyage far the idea presented
within cosmic horror is that we should
remain content with
our bubble of ignorance for we attempt
the piecing together of dissociated
knowledge it would lead to the discovery
of form so terrible and inconceivable
that they would drive one man upon the
revelation of their existence is the
Black Goat truly an entity or myth
propped up by a misguided people core or
remains prosperous shepherding caravans
into the further reaches of the east its
walls of strong stones stand high
defended by unsullied soldiers though
the Lovecraftian references are clear it
remains uncertain whether some of the
more abominable tales of qohor have been
exaggerated though there is much
evidence to support them